[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
you might be surprised to learn that the
largest desert in the world
is not the sahara or the gobi or even in
saudi arabia
it's in antarctica it's called the
antarctic polar desert
and this desert is an ice sheet covering
approximately
5.5 million square miles
its windstorms get up to 200 miles an
hour
its temperature can plummet to minus 129
degrees fahrenheit
yet this freezing area is extremely dry
and gets less than two inches of
precipitation a year
strangely this polar desert sits on top
of
seventy percent of all the world's fresh
water
but it's locked in about six million
cubic miles
of ice averaging 7 000 feet thick
if this massive volume of ice should
melt it would raise global sea levels
about 200 feet
how bizarre that the world's biggest
desert should contain most of the
world's fresh water
you know the bible says that god can
provide water for his people
even in the driest desert stay with us
friends we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends bible answers
live is designed to do our best to
answer
your bible questions if you have a bible
question we have lines open
the number to call into the studio is
800-463-7297 that translates to 800
god says and you could also watch the
program we're streaming
on facebook and that would be the doug
batchelor facebook page
or the amazing facts facebook page and
we invite you right now if you call in
with your bible questions
excellent opportunity that you're going
to get your question on tonight's
program we're dealing specifically
with the word of god may not have all
the answers on finance
and romance but we'll do our best to
give you bible answers so if you
have a bible question give us a call now
one more time the number
800-463-7297 and my name is doug
batchelor
my name is john ross and good evening
friends and as pastor doug mentioned
welcome to bible answers live
and we're going to start with the word
of prayer dear father we thank you that
we can take time and open up your word
and study
no matter where we are we know the
spirit is there and so we do pray for
your guidance and a clear understanding
of what the bible teaches
in jesus name amen amen pastor doug when
you think of a desert you think of a
very
hot place i mean you've got some of the
great deserts of the world in africa
you've got the sahara desert and many
others but
the last thing that really comes to mind
we think of a desert is one of the
coldest places on the planet
with a lot of snow and ice you don't
think of that as a desert but sure
enough
the biggest desert in the world yeah
very little rain
and theoretically if you don't have a
way to melt the ice you could die of
thirst there
it's surrounded by water but it's frozen
it makes me think about how when the
lord led his people through the
wilderness
and they were there in that great vast
desert of the
well it may have been saudi arabia or
the sinai peninsula the
the juries out about exactly what part
of the desert wilderness it was
that they asked for water and moses was
instructed to
strike the rock and out came water
you know it talks about this if you read
in isaiah chapter 35
it says then shall the lame man leap
like the deer
and the tongue of the dumb will sing for
waters will burst
forth in the wilderness and streams
in the desert there are several
occasions in the bible where god
miraculously provided water
you remember when samson had his
encounter and he killed a thousand
philistines he said
he was dying from thirst and he said
lord here you've given me this victory
i'm dying from thirst
and it says the lord claimed a place in
the valley there
and he was able to drink when um
hagar was wandering in the wilderness
and she
and ishmael were dying of theirs god
miraculously gave them water
god gave water to elisha when he was
going through the desert
and the angel provided and then jesus
meets this woman at the well
she comes to draw water and he says i've
got water
that if you drink the water i'm offering
and this is the gospel of john chapter 4
it will be an artesian well of water
springing up
satisfying your spiritual thirst and i'm
paraphrasing of course but that's what
he was talking about that living water
that jesus offers
through the gift of salvation and the
power of the holy spirit
and that water friends if you are
thirsting for life is available to
everybody right now for the asking we've
got a free book we'd like to make
available tonight if you'd like to know
how to receive christ and receive the
holy spirit
and all you have to do is call the book
that we have
is called life in the spirit and that is
our free offer we'll be happy to send
that out to anyone who calls and asks
and we want to encourage you take the
time to give us a call because we'll be
able to mail it to you and you can
actually have
the hard copy in your hand you can read
it you can share it with somebody else
to get that just call 800-835-6747
that is the resource phone line again
it's 800-835-6747
ask for the book called life in the
spirit
all about the holy spirit and you'll be
blessed
well pastor doug we really go to the
phone lines it's been a while since
we've actually
done bible answers live live i know a
number of the folks who've been
listening you've probably the last few
weeks have heard some
some encore and that is because we've
just finished up recently
a bible prophecy seminar yes revelation
now
and i know many of our listeners
probably tuned into that
and we just want to you know mention how
much of a blessing that
series of presentations or lessons were
to so many people around the world i
want to let you know it's still
available for free at the revelation now
website and if you happen to miss any of
those programs
take a look at that and you'll be
encouraged all right we've got george
listening in new jersey george welcome
to the program
welcome to bible and live okay good
evening pastors uh i
did see some of that i did see some of
that
revelation now seminar and i found it
since you're talking about it very
enlightening and inspirational so
there's a few i
didn't see so i'll try to catch them you
know on your site there
thank you yeah we're glad you saw that
yes very good uh tonight's question was
on ezekiel 32 21
how do we reconcile that with the idea
that sheol is supposedly a place of
silence
and unconsciousness that verse and also
near the end of ezekiel
32 that talks about pharaoh who
supposedly is dead
seeing his multitudes uh down below and
he's comforted by them
how do we try to reconcile that with the
belief of
people being unconscious of death it
seems like a difficult verse and
i guess you're familiar with the one in
isaiah 2. isaiah 14 is a little bit
like that too all right well let's start
with you let's start with ezekiel and
for those who are listening i really
need to read the verse so that they have
the context
we always try and be mindful that so
many of our friends listening are
there on the road the listening on
satellite radio and can't like
stop and reopen the bible it says here
in ezekiel chapter 32 verse 21
and it's a prophecy about egypt being
punished
ezekiel i just got done reading the book
of ezekiel in this section of the book
he goes through a series of prophecies
pronouncing judgments
on the enemies of israel and he goes
through everything from
tyre and the and the ammonites
in egypt and
this is the prophecy specifically about
egypt here
and he said the strong among the mighty
shall speak to him out of the midst of
hell
with whose help they have gone down they
lie with the uncircumcised slain by the
sword
so this is clearly speaking about those
who are
slain but in these prophecies the
prophets are using
a lot of symbolic and spiritual language
they're using a certain kind of poetry
and he's basically saying your judgment
is going to come and if you're talking
anymore you can be talking out of the
grave
and i don't think it's literally meaning
that the slain are going to be talking
to someone else from the grave
he's talking about a judgment and i also
think another point to mention here is
the fact that they are in the grave
speaks in and of itself that judgment
came upon them
just like it speaks about the the blood
of of righteous abel crying out from the
ground
well the blood didn't cry out but the
fact that he had been murdered
that cried out for justice and so i
think in the same way here the enemies
of god's people
they've been you know vanquished and
they're in the grave so to speak
and that's justice it demonstrates god's
power yeah
if you read verse 18 of the same chapter
son of man wail over the multitude of
egypt and cast them down to the depths
of the earth
her and her daughters of the famous
nations with those who go down
to the pit and then again it says down
they'll speak from hell
it's talking about the nation going to
judgment
it's not really talking about any
individual that's and the word
hell here is the word shield which is
often used for the grave right
so i don't know if that helps at
all but uh yeah yes it does uh and
and shiel the definition of that is
really
the state of the dead it's not really a
physical grave right because there's
other
hebrew words for grave right well that's
correct there are other words that they
use for a physical grave it's talking
about
you know when people go down well it's i
think it's also used for the grave too
it's sort of the abode of the dead yeah
right right okay i thank you all right
thanks so much george appreciate your
call again if folks are listening and
they're wondering about the subject of
what happens when a person dies we do
have a study guide it's called are the
dead really dead
and this is free all you'll have to do
is call and ask and we'll be happy to
get in the mail and send it to you
the number is 800-835-6747
after the study guide are the dead
really dead we've got glenn listening in
ohio glenn welcome to the program
so thank you very much for taking my
call this evening
and uh god speaking through isaiah in
chapter number one
seems to address two sets of new moons
and festive days
when we go to 13 he talks about new
moons and festive days and
how they apparently did not do very well
in keeping him he was unhappy with it
but then in chapter four or in verse 14
he talks about your new moons
and your festive days which i hate
is it possible that prophetically he
could be talking about such things as
january february march and
sunday worship christmas easter things
like that
you know well that's a good question i i
don't think this specific verse is
talking about that
if you look for example in isaiah 58 he
talks about the hypocritical worship he
said
you're fasting it doesn't do me it
doesn't do you any good because you fast
for strife
what kind of fast has the lord chosen
the pastor ross might find that verse in
isaiah 58
he said this is the fast that i've
chosen to undo the heavy burden to let
the oppressed go free
so when they were going through the
religious forms and ceremonies and
you're reading in chapter one here
keeping their new moons keeping their
sabbaths and keeping their sacred days
he said you know my soul hates them
verse 14.
i'm weary of burying them when you
spread out your hands i'll hide my eyes
from you
even though you make many prayers and
then he explains
because your hands are full of blood he
said so you're guilty of violence
and yet you say oh but you know it's
like the people who crucified jesus
they wanted to take the bodies off the
cross so they could go home and keep the
passover
well what good is keeping the passover
if you've just killed the messiah
i mean you're not going to get points
for that so it's the same principle here
in the isaiah i think first referring to
these number five
it says this is the fast that i've
chosen isaiah 585 585 yes
yeah i would just wonder you know when
he talks about your new moons and your
sabbaths i wonder if there was specific
what he was talking about it was
different than his
no well i think he meant the way you are
keeping it right and
it's also interesting to note that jesus
refers to the sanctuary when
the israelites apostasized he spoke of
the sanctuary as your sanctuary is lest
you desolate
it's as if god said all right if that's
the way you want to do it
it's not mine anymore it's yours and
when christ began his ministry he says
my house is a house of prayer
but when they rejected jesus in his
teaching he said your house
has left you desolate yeah so good point
okay thanks you're cool glenn uh
darling's listening in alabama darla
welcome to the program
hi good evening good evening
um yes and pastor ross i wanted to say i
have a friend
who's gotten really into studying their
bible which is a good thing but
they've brought up deuteronomy chapter
and really are pushing that black people
are
like the modern they were the israelites
the modern day
israelites based on what they've read
deuteronomy
28 verse 68 and i just
i i didn't know you know they've been
reading the book of gesture and a lot of
different things and i was just trying
to see
um are they on the right track or are
there other verses that will give better
direction
or are there any books i can yeah i
heard of anything of this sort well in
deuteronomy 28
68 it's this is the chapter of the
blessing and the cursing and
68 is still part of the cursing and it's
saying that if you turn away from me and
stop keeping my commandments
and let me read this now verse 68 the
lord will take you back to egypt and
ships by the way of which i said you
shall never see it again
and you shall be offered for sale in
other words you will be slaves again
well everyone knows the children of
israel were slaves in egypt but they
didn't start
in egypt they were not egyptians they
were not from africa they came to
egypt from israel during the time of
joseph during the time of the famine
and they were semitic people they were
descendants from
shem that's where you get the word
semitic and so there is a sect of people
out there that try to make a case that
the ancient jews were actually from
africa and there's really no biblical
evidence for that
and of course we also recognize the jews
are not by any means the first nation of
people
who are made slaves slavery has been
around seems like from the very
beginning where one group of people
is you know enslaving another group of
people
and that was typically what occurred
during war time
those who were conquest in battle often
they would be sold for slaves
and so slavery is not limited to a
particular group of people
yeah and of course not only were the
whole nation of israel were slaves with
the exception of moses but
before they ever got there abraham isaac
jacob it says they had servants yeah so
yeah it was just sort of ubiquitous
in the ancient world but um yeah i've
run into some friends that they tried to
make an argument and say that
you know that history has been rewritten
and the bible's been corrupted that the
original jews
were actually from africa and
you know i just i don't see that in
everything i've studied in history it's
very clear
even dna studies are very clear that
the jews were semitic people they're
related to the arabs who are also a
semitic people that descended from
abraham and ishmael and
isaac and they came from mesopotamia
just as the bible said he came out of er
of the counties so anyway you know some
but if uh sometimes it won't matter how
many scriptures you give a person if
they don't want to believe it there's
nothing you can do
anyway i hope that helps a little bit
darla and appreciate that you're calling
and listening
are there any books that you know of
that could help on this topic
well you know you're always at a
disadvantage when you're trying to
disprove
a lie it's so much easier to point to
the truth than try to
prove account or disprove a counterfeit
through familiarity
with the account you find in genesis
it's very clear you know if you believe
it as soon as people
say well it's been changed well how do
you argue with that
but if you believe what it says about
abraham coming from mesopotamia
and his descendants went to egypt as
slaves and came back out of egypt
during the exodus it's um yeah that's
what the bible says and
i don't know that there's whole books on
it there probably are books out there
now that i think of it because this is a
it's a common misunderstanding you just
maybe have to search the internet
yeah all right well thank you thanks
wish we could help more
thanks darla bye-bye all right next
quarter that we have
is kennedy listening from rhode island
kennedy welcome to the program
hi pastor i got sponsored it's great to
hear from you guys again now
likewise well my question is more uh
towards holidays as far as like uh as a
christian what kind of holiday should we
celebrate
because sometimes i usually hear the
controversy between um
christmas or valentine's and their
backgrounds
and will that also be based based on
your cultural background as to whether
or not you should celebrate that as a
christian
yeah good question uh there's certainly
nothing wrong
with if a person has a birthday you get
together you thank the lord for another
year of life
are having an anniversary as far as
nations go
if you're in a nation that is
celebrating their freedom or whatever
there's nothing wrong with being
patriotic as long as it doesn't you know
violate any biblical principle in
america
two extremes would be thanksgiving as a
holiday that was
literally established if you read the
proclamation by lincoln
he talks about thanking god the almighty
for his blessings
and repenting of our sins is in his
proclamation because he
issued that during the end of the civil
war
and but when you get to halloween that
would be a holiday that i think
christians should these are two
opposites of course
i think you know it's kind of steeped in
spiritualism and the dead and
if you don't give us a treat we do a
trick and i don't think christians
should uh
memorialize halloween so now when you
get to things like christmas
there's no nothing wrong with
remembering the birth of christ
but you can know with some certainty he
wasn't born december 25th so the date is
not
correct i'd point you to romans 14 at a
time like this where it says in verse 5
one person esteems one day above another
another one esteems every day alike
let each one be fully convinced in his
own mind he who observes the day
observes it to the lord so if you're
going to keep
thanksgiving thank the lord if you're
going to do anything about christmas
don't make it about santa claus
or if you're going to observe easter do
it as
to the lord thanking god for the the
resurrection and
actually easter is also the passover
season so
you know that's the advice that paul
gives and if you don't don't condemn a
brother that doesn't
um what what about valentine's day
because sometimes valentine's
when i do some research research on that
as well and it kind of seems like
valentine's
was um or you know was do i get the
origin of it it's more like based on
mary's mother
as you know based on the roman catholic
as they started the reformation with
martin luther
then you know they're keeping up with
statues and things like that and they
started keeping the statues and then you
know that commemoration with that so any
background in that as well for any
references
yeah well again if you're gonna
if the world is using a day and they're
saying this is the day
to tell your wife or your girlfriend or
somebody that you love them
is that violating the biblical principle
now it may be
that you know some of these things
sprang from pagan traditions
but um if anything is not of faith
james says if if it's not a faith it's
sin so if you've got doubts
don't do it um but you know if you're
comfortable
then and say you know i i don't see that
there's a violation of any principle and
giving my wife a card with a heart on it
then you might get extra points
you're white so yeah i
and i i agree some of these things do
spring from
you know there's a lot of things we do
that spring from pagan traditions that
aren't necessarily bad
i don't know why we you know wear ties
or shake hands there's no bible command
bible says greet each other with a holy
kiss but we shake hands
so you know that can be traced from a
certain european customs and
there's nothing wrong with it uh there's
no violation of principle so
you know if there's a custom paul says
custom to whom customers do as long as
it doesn't violate a biblical principle
thank you so much all right hey thanks
so much i appreciate your question candy
all right we've got time for another
caller we've got um kathleen
i believe it is in arizona kathleen
welcome to the program yeah
hi thank you thank you both hi pastor
ross pastor
bapler um i want you to know that i pray
for your ministry every night
for safety and that you reach the whole
world so jesus can come
oh thank you so much you're welcome my
question is about the
10 virgins and why why are they
10 is why not another number
and then why do the five wives tell the
five foolish to go buy the oil when the
when the holy spirit cannot be bought
well they're basically saying it's not
that you can buy it i think they're
basically saying you must get for
yourself
and in a sense you know jesus says and i
think pastor ross says it's revelation 3
when he says i counsel thee to buy of me
gold tried of the fire isaiah talks
about something that you buy without
money and without price so you're right
you cannot buy
the holy spirit with money peter said to
simon
you know you perish to think that you
could buy the holy spirit with money
but when you surrender your heart it's
like david says what shall i render
to the lord i will give him my heart
and so you know when we surrender our
hearts to the lord we invite the holy
spirit that's the kind of
buying and by the way the parable of the
10 virgins for our friends that are
listening is found in matthew chapter
25.
um as far as five what do you think
pastor ross just the number ten
five wise five foolish yeah it's
interesting you've got five in the bible
that often has to do with doctrine and
teaching you've got the first five books
the word of god so here you had those
who not only had an understanding of the
doctrine but they actually had the
application of
the truth they had the spirit within
them um
so 10 of course you got the 10
commandments which is a significant
number
but you just got two groups so those are
professed followers of christ they all
have
the oil they all have a certain amount
of the oil but the difference is
there are those who have the oil in the
vessel meaning they have it in their
heart it's not an intellectual
understanding but it's practical
and i think five represents doctrine
teaching yeah
it's like the uh parable of the rich man
he says i've got five brothers
that's talking about the jews had the
five books of moses right
that all of them agreed on oh that's a
great point yeah yeah
and also you know what's interesting is
you've got this number five and you've
got the wise and the foolish
these were all believers that were
looking for the coming of christ
and yet even amongst those who were
looking for christ coming
there were those who are lacking in the
in the oil and that's an important
lesson i think even for us today
all right maybe we can go to one more
quick caller before the break we have
keisha from new jersey keisha we have
just like
two minutes hello pastor doug and pastor
ross good night this is my first time
calling
in so i am honored to be able to speak
with you
yes um i have a question i've been
studying the bible a lot and i've been
finding out
new things but there is something in
jeremiah
10 verses 3
2 6 that i'm having a little issue with
i i want to know if this is
about christmas all right let's read
that together in jeremiah chapter 10
i'll start with verse three
for the customs of the people are futile
for one cuts a tree in the forest the
work of the hands of the workmen with an
axe
they decorate it with silver and gold
they fasten it with nails and hammers
so it will not topple they're up like
upright like the palm tree
but they cannot speak they must be
carried
jeremiah here is talking about idolatry
people the customs of the people pagans
they would go cut a tree
they'd carve it into one of their gods
they'd played it with gold and silver
they'd carried around people would pray
to it it really has nothing to do with
the custom of the christmas tree
now i'm not endorsing the christmas tree
i'm just saying this verse
is not about christmas trees it's about
idolatry
and it's talking about it says these
gods they cannot go by themselves that's
verse 5
they cannot speak don't be afraid of
them they can't do good they can't do
evil
so it's really about when they'd go and
they'd take a piece and then isaiah says
the same thing he said
you go and you cut a tree out of the
woods and he said you take part of that
tree and you cook your dinner and you
take the other part you make a god and
you pray to it
and he said it's a piece of wood so
there's several verses like this where
they kind of uh
they mock the people for their idolatry
and kind of like when i elijah said you
better shout you got a little louder
maybe he's sleeping
so they used to give the bale worshipers
a hard time
hey thank you very much for your call i
appreciate that keisha i hope it helps a
little bit by the way we have a book we
can offer you called baptized paganism
that does talk about some of the pagan
rituals and customs
and if you'd like to receive that again
the number is 800-835-6747
as pastor doug mentions it's called
baptized paganism
and i think you'll find it interesting
to call and ask for it
all right now don't go anywhere friends
we usually take a little break half time
we catch our breath get a drink of water
and you hopefully we'll think of some
new bible questions give us a call
because we're going to do our
best answers in the second half of the
broadcast
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive
and probably telling stories about his
floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore
major bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible
and draw closer to god's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends this is bible answers
live and if you joined us in route
this is a live international interactive
bible study
and we're on hundreds of stations
land-based stations as well as satellite
radio and we just invite you to call in
with your bible questions and we will do
our best
we do see we have a few people standing
by but we still encourage you to call in
because
we're going to try and get through as
many questions as we can
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and pamela is listening so
we'll go to her in alabama pamela
welcome to the program
thank you so much and good evening to
both of you
um i have a question how do you know
when god stops hearing you or
or kept quits trying to get you to come
to him
well i think that you know the bible
says that where there's life there's
hope in the book of ecclesiastes
and in romans chapter 8 it tells us that
there is nothing that can separate you
from the love of god
so god is love he still desperately
loves you
and i'm quite sure he has not given up
on you
as long as you have an interest to turn
towards
god the bible promise in the book of
james chapter 4
it says if we draw near to god he will
draw
near to us and i'm sure that's how he
feels about youtube pamela were you
asking for yourself
or are you asking on behalf of someone
else
uh pamela i think we lost are you there
yeah pamela can you hear me here can you
hear me yes were you asking for yourself
are you wondering sometimes if god has
given up on you
i am and also from someone else as well
yeah you know the very fact that you're
picking up the phone and asking us
is an indicator that you are drawing
near you are reaching out
towards god now you may feel like
sometimes he hasn't
answered your prayers and and there may
be days that seem dark but
god's love for you has not changed i'll
promise you that
and jesus is still desperate for you to
be saved
god so much wants to save you he was
giving
giving his son the life of his son to do
that
so never doubt his love for you
you know how do you know if he hears
your prayers
i mean how i guess i really don't
understand how it is that you're
supposed to talk to him
so that you know he hears you well you
don't have to speak
louder because god knows what you think
before you even pray
the praying is actually helping you
draw near to god god knows everything
you think he hears every prayer you pray
and and he will answer every prayer of
faith
the bible tells us jesus is more willing
to ask or to answer than we are to ask
can i send you a book that deals with
faith and prayer that i think might
encourage you a little bit
i would love it okay we're gonna we'll
send you something special
and it's talking about the uh the gift
of prayer
yeah we have a book called teach us to
pray yes that's all about dealing with
principles of making prayer meaningful
you know pamela we will send you two
books uh ask for the book
teach us to pray but also ask for the
book assurance
justification made simple there's a lot
of christians out there or folks who are
not quite sure if they are
christians maybe they have tried to
confess their sins and maybe they've
plagued with doubt well this book will
be an encouragement to you so ask for
the book teach us to pray
it's about prayer and then ask about the
book assurance
justification made simple and if you'd
like to receive that the phone line is
eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five sixty
seven forty seven
and uh those books are free by the way
yeah we'll just send them to you get in
the mail and you'll have it in a few
days
thank you we have mandy listening from
florida there's a melbourne
in florida i know there's a melbourne
name australia australia yeah
this one's probably a little smaller
than you on the phone
hi i i i'm
so happy to be talking to the both of
you um
doug mr doug batchell i have been
watching you ever since i was
a little little kid and my brother's a
huge huge fan of you and
um our family struggled so much but one
thing my brother always clung to besides
the bible was the
richest caveman book that he still has
the cough work to this day
oh wow well that's a an honor and it's a
delight to talk to you
thank you thank you um i had so
so many questions but i guess um since i
can't really think of any i i'm
nothing that that i can feel like i
could share over
the okay over the radio but i do have
one question that's been nagging me
um i don't want to say nagging but has
been thought provoking um
i'm reading in ezekiel chapter eight yes
and it's very very interesting in some
of the language that
uh it uses and quite specific
actually and i'm wondering i i noticed
that in old
old testament um there's
a lot of writing that refers to the
end time prophecy of course but ezekiel
specific i feel
and i don't know if my guess is question
is
is ezekiel chapter 8 pointing to
the antichrist system
um it is that a future vision that
points to the
antichrist system that was my question
okay andy no no problem
now i'll have to encourage all those who
are listening to read ezekiel 8 because
it's it'll take quite a while for me to
read the whole chapter to everybody
right now
but it's a prophecy where uh the prophet
ezekiel
who is in uh persia is in babylon
and he is being shown what's happened he
was part of the captivity that was
carried away early with daniel
he's being shown some of the
abominations that are being
carried on where outwardly they're
acting like they're serving the lord but
inwardly they're actually still praying
to tammuz and false gods
does some of this have to do with the
last days well there's some of the same
principles that you'll see
uh in the last days where there's
hypocrisy in the church
and counterfeit worship ezekiel's being
shown when a wall is broken through that
leaders
were they were worshiping pagan gods and
so when judgment came
on israel back in the days of ezekiel
when nebuchadnezzar came back and he
finally burned
the temple and destroyed the city he
ezekiel was warning them this was coming
if they did not repent of their sins so
um i think that primarily this prophecy
is talking about what was happening
among the people of israel in his day
but there's some of those things that i
think apply to the last days too
yeah he's an interesting pastor that
specifically the the sin that's
highlighted here is
these 25 men they have their back to the
temple and yet they're bowing worshiping
the rising sun
it's like sun worship that's right and
that's way back in israel's then of
course all of the babylonians worshipped
the sun and
the egyptians the egyptians it crept
even into
some christian circles which is kind of
interesting yep all right well thank you
mandy appreciate your call we have jack
listening from
colorado jack welcome to the program
good evening how are you good thank you
for calling
in your question tonight quick question
probably a short answer in acts
2 verse 13 it says
others mocking said these are men
these men are full of new wine right
and i was
disputing with man that uh not speaking
against
talking and he um i would say he was
saying oh jesus turned the water into
wine fermented wine i said no he turned
a new one he said no
in acts 2 13 it says they these men are
drunk of
uh new wine so could you clarify for me
the difference between new wine
unfermented wine in the bible yes we'll
do our best
pasta dough let me just jump in here
real quick pasta if you look at the word
translated as new wine it's directly the
word means sweet wine
or it's not fresh grape juice
it's a different word so it's translated
as new wine but it's more accurately
translated as
sweet wine or intoxicating wine of
course
the passover uh occurs uh or pentecost
occurs
um 50 days after peso 50 days after
passover
but the harvest of grape was not until
august so they wouldn't have been able
to
obtain fresh grape juice so that new
wine
is not fresh grape juice it's some kind
of a fermented drink
and they're saying well these people are
drunk yeah
and you know i love that yeah so the
you know clearly um when jesus said i
will not drink the fruit of the vine
unless i drink it with you new in my
father's kingdom
that there's talking about grape juice
and that's at the last supper so even at
the last supper
christ is saying that um you know they
would drink new wine
incidentally the word they knew wine is
translated from the greek glucose
that's the word yeah glucose sweet wine
oh i love it so it was a different word
yeah quickly quickly i agree with both
of you i am a seventh-day adventist and
thank you so much and the revelation now
ceremony
seminars have been just a blessing to my
family and thank you so much for all of
that
i've signed up for the new asco thing um
that you guys
did i'm so excited and thank you and i
believe
yeah by the way and so thank you for
taking michael yeah absolutely well
before you go away though
there's a book we have that gives more
answers on this
in uh more detail and we'll send you a
free copy jack
it's called alcohol and the christian
that's right it sounds like you studied
the subject but you might want to share
it with a friend
uh the bible or the rather the that
phone number there
is 800-835-6747 that's the telephone
that's the resource phone line
call and ask for the book on i'll call
in the christian web happy to send it to
you and again read it and then share it
to somebody else
we've got john listening in michigan
lansing michigan john welcome to the
program
thank you yeah and your question
um so my question is um
can sin transfer through generations
and if so or if there's anything kind of
relevant
to that is there a way
um to be absolved of that
if if you if you're feeling like maybe
the sins of your fathers or forefathers
that you're suffering for that somehow
yeah
all right because i've asked for yeah go
ahead sorry
you you don't have to worry that you
know let's suppose
your father um that he stole a bunch of
money from
an employer or something and that
somehow now you're going to be paying
for his sin
uh the lord says in both ezekiel i think
it's in the law of moses too i think
it's ezekiel 18.
the son well let me the son will not
suffer for the penalty of the father and
the father will not suffer for the
penalty of a son
and you can read it says i'm in ezekiel
18 14 however if he begets his son
if he gets a son which sees all the sins
which his father has done
and considers but does not do likewise
he's not eaten on the mountain he's not
lifted his eyes to idols so forth
it says that you know he's not he says
he will surely live
he will not die for the iniquity of his
father now i'm quoting word for word
verse 17.
that son will not die for the iniquity
of the father he will live it's
basically saying
that the righteousness of the righteous
will be upon him the only time it talks
about generational sin
is when the children pick up the habits
of the parents and they they reproduce
the behavior of the parents
that's why it tells us in even the ten
commandments
unto the third and fourth generation of
those that hate me
but showing mercy unto thousands of
those that love me and keep my
commandments so
um the only way the generational sin
works is if a person follows in the sins
of their parents
and the virtue referring to there in
exodus exodus chapter 20 verse five
part of the ten commandments it talks
about uh iniquity
till the third and fourth generation of
those who hate me so
it's interesting to pass you've got
three different words in the bible
for sin you've got sin you've got
transgression you've got iniquity
iniquity carries with the sort of the
the motivation
it's the selfishness and it seems as
though it's quite possible for a child
to through observation i in
sort of inherit or receive that selfish
strong
selfish propensity it seems to be
carried on generation by generation
and that's what the bible's warning
against it doesn't have to be that way
but
it quite often works out that way if
somebody doesn't um
put christ in their life yep they say
your kids pick up your bad character
traits
yeah so if you read ezekiel 18 the main
subject in that chapter
is explaining the parents do not suffer
for the sins of the children and the
children do not suffer for the sins of
the parents
so i think it'll be real clear there
thank you john i appreciate your
question
all right next caller that we have is
ron
and he's a truck driver in florida ron
welcome to the program
hey uh good evening passes how you doing
i'm doing great
and your question great um appreciate
your ministries uh my question is um
john 3 13. um
some someone was trying to i believe
that elijah
enoch and moses is in heaven but they
were trying to use this text to say
that they didn't go to heaven john 3 13.
yeah it's a great verse i mean uh pastor
you jump in yet too but one of the ways
i've
understood this first jesus is talking
um to nicodemus here in john chapter
three and the issue being
referred to here is is truth and he says
how can a man be born again years old
jesus says well you're ruling israel you
don't know these things and then he says
no one has ascended up into heaven
except him that has come down
and that's in the context of coming to
share truth or share
heavenly truth um it's true
you know we have elijah that went up to
heaven but he didn't come back he never
came back to teach people
moses was resurrected take you to heaven
he didn't come back and gather group
together and say well let me explain
some of the doctrines but jesus came
down from heaven oh yeah yeah
jesus came down from heaven specifically
to
talk about heavenly things so yeah he's
talking about
yeah jesus is the only one who came from
the father to reveal the truths of
heaven
that makes sense thank you i appreciate
that it does it does i think my friend
of mine we
we kind of came to that conclusion but i
thank you for that confirmation i
appreciate that
all right hey thanks so much for calling
ron i appreciate it
and of course pastor nicodemus would
have known about
elijah going to heaven and enoch going
to heaven i mean that was part of the
old testament he was familiar with that
and even moses because i think it was
part of a jewish tradition
yeah about the assumption of moses yeah
all right we've got um
james in michigan ann arbor michigan
james welcome to the program
hey how you all doing i'm doing good
and your questions good yeah yeah i had
a question uh
i'll go through this real quick uh i got
a question about clean and unclean
animals it does
in the book of leviticus it's also
because i've heard people saying like
these vaccines are like the mark of the
beast
so it kind of ties into the whole thing
but the book of leviticus it says that a
pig
and any fowl or bird that creeps upon
the ground
shall be unclean to you shall not eat it
and the pig gave us
like swine flu that killed like 50
million people in 1918
right and the chicken carries 18
different types of flu
and then they're banning minks in europe
right now these mink farms for fur
because they carry coronavirus
then they think the coronavirus came
from these wet animal markets
in china that had all these unclean
animals like ferrets and
bats and armadillos yeah
yeah actually it's a pangolin it wasn't
an armadillo penguins yeah
yeah yeah and so it's like but the thing
that
that that gets me is we keep coming up
with these vaccine
and instead of banning these unclean
animals like pigs and chickens or at
least
not having these factory farms that are
all crowded together we keep eating
these animals and we just come up with a
vaccine every year and we kind of go oh
we got a vaccine now we can keep eating
unclean animals and having these factory
farms which spread disease now the
antibiotics are getting drug resistant
because the farmers use them so much
yeah and it's like the vaccines become
kind of uh
it's our uh our remedy yeah well it's
exactly it's a mark
too it's like a mark that goes in your
right hand and you can also
inhale them now they have under your
tongue you can inhale the vaccines like
a spray
and it's in your right hand and it so in
and your forehead so it is like
it comes from the beast of the earth and
it's a mark we take in our arm
and then we keep abusing these animals
well they're unclean and i'm
with you on the part about we're a lot
better off if we don't eat these unclean
animals
i don't think i'm i'm with you that the
mark of the beast is a vaccine in the
hand and the forehead
and we do have a lesson we'll send you
on that but
yeah there's no question that it's odd
that instead of dealing with the problem
so many of these
deadly viruses come from humans
living in close proximity with unclean
animals
whether they're well but i don't think i
don't think vaccines you know there were
there were millions of people saved from
like smallpox vaccine years ago and
diphtheria and others and so i don't
think vaccines are of the devil or
they're the mark of the beast
now i don't know about this next vaccine
i mean i they say i hear they're doing
some interesting things and developing
it yeah
a little bit well that's what i'm saying
in the bible it says the people that
take the mark of the gist get a grievous
sore on the
hand or the forehead and it also says
the beast makes people
take the mark of the beast in the rain
or they can't buy or sell and they're
kind of talking about stuff like that
now like
you got to get the vaccine to go on a
trip you got to get a vaccine to go
maybe to a restaurant i don't know so
it's all
yeah it is interesting it is interesting
yeah i mean you look at that but you
know in the in the broader context
revelation is about worship that's
that's the
issue who are we going to worship and so
we're going to worship the beast so
we're going to worship god
but it is interesting how that uh
political powers can just
influence the populations of the world
overnight
you know we do see a battle taking place
in the western world between uh states
and religion a lot of religions are
saying we need to meet in worship and
the states are saying you can't because
of the
the virus and that they've you know
having supreme court cases dealing with
that right now
so i can see where uh certainly
through the pandemic certain issues have
come to a head and it seems like a lot
of americans have lost
even judge alito said we're losing
freedoms
people are getting used to surrendering
freedoms to the states
because the the excuse you know the
pandemic can be used as an excuse for
many things
so um yeah it is an issue to um
i think be alert to yeah so uh if i see
people breaking out with sores after the
vaccine i know i'm not getting it
you won't be the first in line no i'm
not i'm not gonna be i don't want you
know one they
say don't be the first one to download
new software that's right
i'm not going to be the first that's for
sure all right well thanks james we
appreciate your goal
we have emily in washington emily
welcome to the program
hello hi thank you for calling
thanks for taking my call i have a
question
about luke 17 3 okay that's been
bothering me for a while
it says if your brother sins against you
rebuke him
rebuke him and if he repents forgive him
so what happens if he doesn't repent
then i don't have to forgive him
what's the word if doing there well
that's a good point
by the way i have a message on
forgiveness you can
watch for free at youtube if you just
type in doug batchelor
and it's called 70 times seven because
it's a big issue how does a christian
deal with forgiveness
there's two things that are happening
one is when you forgive another person
what does it do for them
and then when you forgive what does it
do for you
the idea of being unforgiving
did jesus wait until his killers
apologized before
he forgave them or did he say father
forgive them they know not what they do
so you can choose to forgive a person
even if they don't repent
it doesn't mean now someone steals from
you and they don't apologize you know
don't lend them any more money
because you you're not helping them
you're not helping you
but you don't want to be bitter against
them forever because that bitterness
you know poison corrodes the container
that holds it
so you might need to forgive them and
let it go for your
own spiritual health you don't have to
ever
be involved or trust them again and also
forgiveness carries with it a degree of
restoration the relationship has been
restored and i think that's the context
here right
you know if if you confront him and he
recognizes the fault
and repents then you can restore the
relationship so
forgiveness in that sense is not only
just forgiving but it's
a restoration of the relationship
yeah good point hey thank you so much um
now we do have
um like i said that a video you can
watch for free it's called 70 times
seven just
type in bachelor and that's b a t c
h e l o r 17 times seven and i spent
about 45 minutes talking about
forgiveness there
i've heard that sermon several times
past i think it's one of my favorite i
only know two sermons you probably heard
them all
that one i remember that was a good one
all right we've got gail
in canada gail welcome to the program
gail you with us you might have your
mute on gail we'll give you one more
chance here gail in canada larrange
canada
hello there she is okay yeah you made it
just
underneath we got a minute and a half
can we do a quick question
uh sure um uh i have a question
in heaven you've mentioned in your
um revelation now that god winks at some
of
our sin so i'm not sure
jacob has two wives reisha and leia
so is he going to have two wives in
heaven
and there are also people that has
tattoo but they have already accepted
christ
so but you but it is stated in the bible
that um we will be having glorified
bodies so i don't know how to
perceive that yeah well two questions
uh when it comes to being in heaven i
doubt that solomon's going to have
all 700 wives and 300 concubines in the
kingdom
you know jesus talks about that when i
think it's in matthew pastor ross where
he said
those who are worthy to obtain the
resurrection neither marry nor are they
given in marriage but there is the
angels
so jacob in heaven is principally going
to be married to the lord it's
it's not that uh he's he'll probably
have a good relationship with rachel lee
and the others but
it's not going to be like earthly
marriage there as far as tattoos
you know people come to the lord with
all kinds of sins and scars
and that they may have obtained in their
former life
the lord accepts us the way we are and
you just come
as the song says just as i am without
one plea
and so if a person's we we had a friend
that was covered with tattoos
literally from head to foot he he had
tattoos
but all kinds of interesting tattoos he
said pastor doug said you know if i try
and get all these removed and he didn't
actually try to remove several of them
he said it can be very painful
he said i'm going to look pretty bizarre
and he just he had a dramatic conversion
and you know he's going to get a new
body tattoo free when he come when jesus
comes so
uh you just you know you come to the
lord the way you are and
and uh yeah his mother might be the only
one that recognizes him
at first in heaven but yeah so anybody's
for people out there and if you've got
tattoos you know if you just come to
jesus it says yeah you shouldn't do it
but if you did it you didn't know
god winks at our ignorance he accepts us
the way we are
and then i wouldn't go get any new
tattoos right
so hey friends you know i want to be
fair to take another question because
we're coming up on the close of the
program we do by the way if you do stay
by we have some important announcements
i think that you'll be blessed by
and take a look at revelation now the
program we just recorded it's at the
website
revelationnow.com you can view all those
programs on prophecy
talks about where we are in history now
it's all free
god bless will study his word together
again next
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand
your bible even better than before bible
answers live
is produced by amazing facts
international a faith-based ministry
located in granite bay california
[Music]
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
journey back through time to the center
of the universe
discover how a perfect angel transformed
into satan
the archvillain the birth of evil
a rebellion in heaven a mutiny
that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet
and the first humans witness the
temptation and evil
discover god's amazing plan to save his
children
this is a story that involves every life
on earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if god is good
if god is all-powerful if god is love
then what went wrong
[Music]
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more bible answers
live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions
you